so tell us all about this suit what is
it what's it called why do you use it
where do you use it and how you use it
so this is my sock all space suit only
used for the emergency situation that
the air would actually leak after the
spacecraft so we wear it for the
dangerous times the times when you're
most likely to leak the air out
that's the launch the docking and then
the landing again and as soon as the
launch is finished and you can unstrap
from the seats it's about two and a half
hours after the launch but nonetheless
as soon as that's done then you can take
off your spacesuit big blue valve on the
front is really useful so that if you do
inflate the spacesuit yeah and then you
have to do some maneuver which is going
to be really difficult to do because
you've inflated then you can use that
valve to decrease the pressure inside it
so you can decrease the pressure you
check this little valve thing on the
suits arm to see what pressure you've
decreased it to okay and for memory that
goes down to a point two six in the
atmosphere that's not really very much
oxygen to breathe yeah so you can do
that for a new short time before you
then need to rest again and then use
this big blue valve on the front to
increase the pressure back up to point
four of an atmosphere and then that's
enough for you to breathe and to survive
and you can do that repeatedly until
you've got the maneuver done that you
need to do if one wanted to go and get a
spacesuit where would you go me neither
they measure you in so many different
places it's done in the same factory
where they made Gagarin spacesuit but
they made even like his spacesuit so you
feel rather special that you're taking
part yeah one thing that really strikes
me sort of being here looking at the
cosmonaut exhibition but in particular
is that the beginnings of our
exploration of space are going back to
1957 with Sputnik happened in the same
place and we're pretty much using the
same equipment as we as we're using from
back then I mean the suit is very
similar to Gagarin suit and Tereshkova
suit
very much part of the Soviet political
system there so she had to to do what
they were asking her to do in terms of
promoting what she had done and she gave
me advice before my lunch she came to me
and the something breakfast to formally
send me off many times when I was there
she would pop round and just just for a
chat and make sure everything was fine
I'm very very kind person and have
people like that who would be so we were
just actually getting on with life as
many people we've got all of that
propaganda from the US about going to
the moon I remember as a child savings
silver.look boil tops to make a picture
of an Apollo spacecraft but we didn't
get the Soviet propaganda because they
just chose to keep it to themselves I
think it's only actually when I was
there I realized how significant what
they had done they were the first people
in space they got the first spacewalk
the first full moon in space they were
the first to do so much and yet Here I
am talking about my spacesuit
in such an amazing historic exhibition
it's just an amazing thing for me to do